well Dortmund is over Cara 101 and his
net and then he'll play in the Olympiad
next week and then he'll come here and
vashu of the Groff was winning handily
but he lost today so now he's only half
a point ahead so tomorrow's the last
round in Beal which is in what country
Switzerland some call it BN because
there's German and French there and then
Oh what's he doing over there
so I actually played in Beal in 1993 but
it wasn't like the open tournament where
I got beat a lot not the super-g
tournament where other people got beat a
lot okay
so I want to take turns looking at Cara
Juana and vas she'll de Graaf games
you'll know more about them and then
what vas show The Grove is here and wins
the tournament and Caruana will come in
second then we can see what's up now
here
Cara Juana is playing the st. Louis
player Georg Meier who went to Webster
University recently left so he's no
longer a Webster and they have some
other new grandmasters like iliyan is
Nick and some other guys ninja dicks
about the same rating as Meyer but he's
about six years younger okay and this
was played a week ago and this was in
that doesn't work what can I do this
okay
and Meyer always plays the French
defense as in the famous game Alex for
Jill Azov Meyer from two months ago also
played French defense here at the chess
club okay and Caruana and Meyer have
played before and they like to play the
French defense and they like to play
2030 moves of theory if possible if
possible so okay this is the main main
main line of this variation and many
many thousands of Grandmaster games and
in many of those games Carolina was y de
Meyer was black so they're pretty happy
to be repeating this position and both
sides could play differently but well
this is probably the most common line
and a lot of times white place for made
on the Kings side and black place for
made on the Queen side so that way we're
going to have a
face of game queen f2 now blacks got to
be careful because he doesn't want to
lose material but whites really
defending the d4 square he's got his
rook his bishop his queen and black has
a big problem in this position now who
knows what his big problem is other than
he's playing Cara Juana
yeah the juban c8 is a little iffy it's
got about thirty pieces in front of them
both diagonals so now white on the other
hand these bishops can go anywhere
white squared Bishop has lots of squares
and so White's pieces are sort of better
than blacks but black has a nice pawn
here in the center on d5 and white
doesn't have a deep on so that d5 pawn
is pretty good as defending e4 and white
black I should say can play on both
sides black can push his Queen side
pawns black and maneuver his Knight to
c4 and occasionally black will play f6
and attack the e5 pawn if the time is
right and well these are two of the most
theoretically prepared players in the
world and Myer is a really big expert on
the French defense what he must have
forgot all this theory yeah what
happened over here no I know what
happened that's what happened come back
come back Shane okay can Weiss got that
okay okay so yeah so Bishop takes d4 and
then b5 so blacks going to push all
these pawns on the Queen side and
checkmate white and white will resign
that's the plan anyway
okay let's ship back to e3 Queen a5 King
bee one who knows a rule about why white
should play King bee one very important
rule you that's not a rule that's just
that's just why he did it
what's the rule which would indicate
that white should play king b1 it's a
rule I made up I've said it maybe a
thousand times while you're in the
audience always play King b1 easy
remember now you have a question about a
previous position
so we want to trade off to the dark
square bishop
well in my opinion black wants to play
b5 and that opinion is because I saw him
do it otherwise I wouldn't know and you
can't play b5 because you lose your
knight now you're saying we should do
some other way to play b5 like Knight
takes Knight again well then you would
trade more pieces off because after
Knight takes Knight Bishop takes your
Bishop is attacked so I think black
wants to trade off as few pieces as
possible so he can give checkmate
although it didn't work but it's trying
it is very unusual for black to do what
he did I haven't seen that before so I
agree yeah what's wrong with him
terrible no but I think if he plays a
knight takes then he'll have to keep
trading and then he won't be able to
attack so much because it was no way to
attack with no pieces so here he plays
b5 and he starts attacking okay he's
doing a good job so far now because of
what happened what you indicated black
doesn't have a dark squared bishop so
it's hard to play Knight b6 or night c5
moves that you want to play because it's
defended so he went back and he's going
to play a5 a4 and give checkmate
so did white reset now okay so Knight d4
and some trades and a5 so I think black
wants to trade off the white scored
bishops
put his knight on c4 and checkmate Wyatt
again the bishop on C it still hasn't
moved but maybe he'll put a 6 later this
should be 5 which indicates to me he
doesn't want to trade the white square
bishops he's going to take the knight or
play Bishop a4 then he took the night so
now it's going to be hard for blacks to
play Knight c4 unless he promotes to a
knight which is unlikely ok if it
happens I don't know
and so what White's doing is saying
there's going to be no attack this game
you're just going to be worse because my
bishops great and your bishops never
going to do anything and black is
thinking it's opposite bishops we traded
a lot of pieces why don't we agree to a
draw that would be great because he's a
low rated player and he has the black
pieces in Cara Juana doesn't want to
draw because he's white and that would
cost him some reading points so white
did a good job of trading all of blacks
attacking pieces and black did a good
job of getting obviously colored bishops
and good drawing chances g4
so I guess white doesn't want to draw
okay now which player who's not here
right now because he's a New Haven would
like to move g4 no nothing come on you
should know Matt Larson okay Matt
Larson's favorite movies g4 although he
denies it but plays it every game
okay so g4 White's going to attack
normally when you have opposite side
castling you're seeing some pawn storms
okay a 4 B 3 B 3 is an unusual move
normally you don't move pawns in front
of your king but he was probably worried
that black would play b3 and really open
up his King and he wants all of his
pawns on white squares because he has a
dark squared bishop now it's very
difficult for black to play Bishop c4 or
Bishop to d3 but White's bishop controls
a1 so you can imagine black is doubling
up on the a file trying to give me but
the bishop is defending a 1 so there's
no mate Queen c6
not sure why he did that f5 i know why
he did that Bishop to b5 so the reason
he played Queen c6 is he wants to play
Queen a6 and open up the a file as I
indicated earlier although to be honest
with you I don't know I could play King
c1 Bishop b2 so what so okay I guess
that's what happened so rook to d2
defending his c2 pawn takes which way
did white take let's vote I actually
have no idea
so I'll vote too if you didn't take
backup in a lot of trouble okay so
either took with a pawn or the C pawn to
me it's pretty obvious because of what
he just did he's sort of telling me what
he did
he's like hooking me up but now maybe
it's not obvious to you guys
okay although I've been wrong before who
thinks he took with the a pawn I think
she took with the C pawn yeah I think he
took with the C pawn that's why you
played rook to d2 so his rook would
defend a - taking with a pawn would be
weird because then the rook is sort of
blocking his king's escape so I think he
took with the C pawn we did with the a
pawn because it's funnier that way ah
hate when we're all right okay rook a3
is going to triple up on the a file or
try to rook e1 the rooks better on e 1
then H 1 and I remember watching this
game live I didn't see the end of it and
around here computer was saying like it
was about equal like opposite bishops
equal material both sides have a little
attack okay eight Ricky three
now Ricky three is important for two
reasons white wants to checkmate black
with rook h3 Queen h4 and white wants to
stop sacrifices on b3 opening up the a
file now route takes b3 is risky because
the rook can take it
so with this pawn defended by the rook
and that pawn defended by the rook it's
hard for blacks to break through unless
it was a bughouse can then maybe rook c8
threatening Queen c1 mate
now if these were super super super
grandmasters though they are then they
should repeat an agree to a draw rook c1
okay but and Queen e1 was played and
that defends every rank the first trying
the second ring and the third rank seems
like it's hard for white to win because
White's basically defending but I think
he defended against everything rook c7
doing nothing Queen d1 also doing
nothing rook a eight rook e1 everybody
does nothing and black changes his mind
and triples on the C file although like
so what what's blacks next to move I
don't know rook SI toos was next move
what
right I mean black is basically stopping
white from playing queen c1 Queen c2
Rick c2 mouthing black can do anything
okay Queen f3 Queen c1 isn't quite made
now now rook c1 would be made so
probably he stopped it yep
and basically black ran out of ideas
because white defendant everything and
now man that looks pretty good for white
over there on the kingside it's funny
this bishop is defending everything and
that bishop is like sitting there it's
not defending blacks King it's not
attacking White's King it's just sort of
there now if we could cheat a little bit
in i Kang as I have the mouse we could
play like dish at E for now we're
talking
Bishop g6 now that's a good Bishop but
Bishop on b5 isn't really very helpful
the a6 f1 diagonal is not where it's at
G takes f6
I'm not sure what to suggest it looks
hopeless no matter what he does because
he's going to lose on the Kings side now
although I wouldn't play G takes up sex
I'd be too afraid to do that also I'd be
afraid to play g6 too yeah yeah this
looks like I'm just afraid if you play
g6 you know I could play h4 h5 ok takes
rook g8 getting the open G file G v h6
no wonder the lights went off yeah yeah
I wouldn't play h6 so basically black is
smushed he can't do anything
white defended all of blacks threats and
then blacks like well I can't do
anything and now White's the one
attacking age six I would never consider
so I wouldn't do that
Rick g1 g6 Alec g6 let's not call
clearance or something do we have
clearance clearance yeah now Queen h6
mate gives white the advantage I would
assume that he resigned here but I
wouldn't bet my life on it
but I'm pushing a button and nothing's
happening so I think I guessed right
yeah yeah Queen h6 meet with advantage
and there's not much of a defense so
that was sort of a funny game black did
everything to give me and white stopped
it and then he's like okay now it's my
turn
you yeah if he didn't play this silly h6
well I guess white keeps attacking on
the Kings side and black Moses rooks
back and forth and loses so like I play
h4 h5 ripped g1 g6 and I don't know what
you do you really can't with anything
yeah but when I play h5 you're not going
to like that
I play h4 h5 and then you're like oh
well yeah well the difference it's a big
difference between these bishops that
Bishop on b2 is a monster and the other
bishop just sits there and there's even
some positions where I sacrifice on e6
because f7 will be made I mean the
bishop on b2 is looking good so that was
a that wasn't Cara Juana's best game
from the terming he had some really nice
wins but it was pretty good win and my
earth his credit he tied for second so
go st. Louis pretty good how do I go to
the next game maybe this button know
that did that did nothing nothing does
anything alright well let's get rid of
this now that can't be right there we go
okay and this was a game from the same
tournament and he played Michael Adams
what country is Michael Adams from yeah
either is correct but don't say the UK
no yeah this discussion we had yesterday
okay Cara Wan is white and they played
the Berlin everybody's favorite opening
unless you're a spectator okay now it
used to be everybody play d4 went into
this end game and now they're playing
were q1 now they're doing both but okay
he played d4 went to the end game okay
so this endgame has happened thousands
of times and in my opinion black is
doing pretty well
the super GM's agree with that but okay
sometimes you got to try to win with
light and not only did Cara wanna win
we're going to look at another game
where var Sheila Groff wins with white
and this opening also the same week so
the Berlin has got to be on his toes and
usually this is pretty boring Queens are
traded and nothing much happens and lots
of trades happen and blacks pretty
content to draw now if you read a lot of
beginners books like I do it tells you
it's good to have pawn majorities so on
the Kings side white as a pawn majority
for pawns the three on the Queen side
black has a pawn majority also for pawns
of three and the reason people like
white is they think they can get a
passed pawn later but they don't think
black can because black has the double
puns the reason people like black is
black has the two bishops the reason
people like white is blacks King is very
strange blocking the rooks the black
King has to find somewhere safe so okay
people have their adherence to both
sides rook to d2 I guess he's going to
double rooks well he showed me so c5 is
a typical move into Berlin because black
wants to play Bishop to c6 and get his
bishop active but okay gives away the d5
square so okay doubles the rooks
threatening Knight takes b6 check and
probably some other knight moves
attacking the bishop by discovery and
Bishop f4 defending the pawn now in
these kinds of positions which happened
in the Berlin a lot you got to be
careful about c7 because this is
attacking c7 and potentially by x-ray
this is we have like six times we can
take right away so black has to be
careful here King b7 c4 and white is
very patient because he's trying to stop
black from doing anything and blacks
very Paisley thinks it's just a draw
that white can't do anything
Trading bishops does that help white or
black yes why
two bishops exactly we had two bishops
now you don't have two bishops also
White's playing on the Kings side
because white as a pawn majority he got
rid of one of blacks defenders now his
King is moving up his pawn majority is
going I can't say the same for black I
can't say the black's pawn majority is
aggressive or that his king is moving up
so this opening has worked out really
well for white and white has a nice
advantage now black tries to trade all
the pawns off because if you trade all
the plums off your opponent one Queen if
black doesn't do anything then why it's
going to play f4 f5 king f4 and blacks
to be very unhappy which is sort would
happen anyway but trade off some pawns
if possible and white still gets his
majority going black tries to get his
majority going but I mean these two
pawns aren't going to like overpower the
c-4 pawn and White's pretty happy with
his majority and this is actually how
Michael Adams beats people is slowly
slowly slowly wins
so beating somebody like that is pretty
fun when they're trying the one the
squeezing usually and you can see blacks
also pushing his majority but that
didn't work out very well because his c7
pawn is you know as impotent as a button
event Nevada boxing commissioner I got
to work on that joke man I steal the
joke and I still can't say it okay so
pretty bad position for black question
never play off six yeah
you want to play rook d7 and then double
your works on the D file yeah then I
would probably do the same riki to d1
after you do that then yeah I don't know
you got no more piece of his bughouse
you could you know put upon an e6 yeah
yeah thing is the knight on d5 can't be
attacked by anything else just the
bishop so yeah rook d7 I play a for you
double rooks I double rooks then I just
keep going f5 King f4 e6 rawr h4 g5 yep
you usually have six to trade all the
pawns off as a good idea but he didn't
really trade all the puns off okay by
the way I like this rigged D to move I
didn't talk about it but black has one
hope here rook takes a two could take
about 20 moves to do it but after here
now it's hard to do yeah because that's
the only pawn black could really attack
because the other pawns are all
defendants he defended at first then
he'll play g5 when he feels like it I
guess he felt like it man that's a good
pawn majority white has okay now Black's
losing pawns that's not good yeah okay
this is just him not resigning why you
didn't resign here Wow resigning is
recommended if you play rook takes g6
I'll play f7 and if you play rook f6
check I'll move my king then you'll
resign although he played here oh you
didn't resign here either solid and now
you resign because after rook g5 he'll
be a queen so that's not good I expected
resignation earlier but I have high
standards yeah okay so that was a funny
game because White has a pawn majority
that's like real and blacks is a little
fake and then White Queen so yeah so it
makes it look like the it's a terrible
opening for black especially after the
vast year again we're going to look at
but black does pretty well here so that
was impressive how did I do
this would I do I did this and this and
this okay now we looked at two games of
Fabiano now I'll get to my guy MVL and
MVL first two games that he won and Biel
were the exact same except he was black
and one away in the other but the exact
same idea now I'm sure all of you have
memorized the homework I gave you from
before okay an MDL has played Magnus
Carlsen before and he beat him in 100
moves and the game he won there was an
open a an h-file and Magnus had them
both and then he kept doing and then
eventually he broke through now in this
game and the next one I'm going to show
you
MV L breaks through in the a file with
black he does it with white and very
suspicious fashion like you wouldn't
suspect it so he's black and his
Sicilian and his opponent plays the anti
Sicilian Bishop b5 check avoiding the
night off and nobody traded anything for
a long time no trades and it actually
starts to look like a real Lopez but no
trading note reading aloud and black
eventually play d5 so it looked like a
real Lopez okay this looks like just
some random real Oh PES may be a prior
variation and no trading is allowed this
game the players know my rules well
never trade all white traded so now
white loses no trading okay so why has
the open a file for her rook I should
say not his rook now the trades all come
but yeah white is the two bishops but
how you funds Bishop on c2 doesn't look
like the usual Spanish torture Bishop it
looks like it's sort of locked and the
knight on c5 is a monster what a great
night
and there's more trades everybody
thought the game would be a draw because
they'd trade every move he and print he
improved his bishop which was behind all
those pawns some more trades were
happening always repeat and finally what
black did something finally and if I
remember correctly the computer was not
happy with White's decision here white
played 92 yet allowing this it didn't
like and during the game is very
difficult to tell if the plot on g3 is
going to Queen or White's just going to
take it so you got to be sort of careful
here problem with White's position is g5
is a week and the night still has the c5
square the black other Black Knight can
go to c5 so Queen da was an excellent
move attacking the g5 pawn and white
played c4 now if you take on d6 which
looks sort of obvious I guess it's not
obvious because I can do it and then I
take here if we trade Knights this pawn
looks pretty good doesn't it that looks
like it's going to Queen first so how
you fine played c4 and hoping to improve
her Knight
take this pawn take this pawn and
eventually draw the game Queen tanks
attacking the knight Queen takes
defending the knight b4 very strong
positional move because white really
wants to play Knight c4 and attack the
d6 pawn but now 9 c4 is illegal and
therefore not good and not only can
white not play Knight c4
what can black do that's very similar to
94 95
I don't think white has a pawn that's
going to attack the knight on c5 so
White's going to get trouble on c5 the
white knight on g2 is bad and if the
knight moves away
a queen c1 check is annoying and
eventually black could even play f5 h5
an attack on the kingside so she played
knight b3 trying to stop knight c5 and
Queen c1 and this was just brilliant
play by by MVL h5h for now White has an
isolated pawn on g3 and Queen to d8
queen Didier was a masterful move with
what idea which I explained before the
game so you can know because I told you
before the game yeah yeah he wants to
play Queen a a Queen a - and that's
annoying and well the thing is the e4
pawn is quite weak that's probably the
downfall to White's position White's
can't defend the e4 pawn with a pawn so
why it's going to have to keep the Queen
on it or keep the knight on D 292 is
risky because black plays Knight c5
which I indicated earlier and then item
b3 sort of stupid it doesn't defend the
e pawn and black can play Knight f6 and
Queen a2 and white has to defend both
sides of the board so the D pawn it
should be it's a backward pawn it can't
be defended by upon but why can't attack
it but the b2 pawn the e4 pawn the c4
pawn even the g3 pawn those can be
attacked too much for white to handle
Queen a 7 Knight of 6 threatening the
pawn queen a to hard to defend all that
stuff you got to defend efore and B 3
and B 2 and C 4 not good night C 193 b3
and now White's in sort of a zoogs long
it's not clear to me where white can
move because he's defending B 2 and D 3
and E 4
yeah ventually she did to go crazy she'd
just get all our pawns away and pushed
everything and tried to Queen I don't
think she did it yet did she know she
went crazy later when she knew it was
all over um
c5 yeah I'd probably play c5 what's that
oh you mean if I take on c5
yeah I'm mildly worried about something
tell me if I'm right
I've been wrong before if you if I take
this I'm not sure if I should take this
and you take what happens on here it's a
lot of silence
what do we do King f1 a liking f1
although I like this move
I like seeing f1 until that yeah okay
Queen takes Queen all right I recommend
pawn takes Queen whoops the worst Mouse
slip ever well yeah I know now we got to
stop the pawn somehow and then yeah
there we go
yummy this nights going to be good on d6
and blacks going to play f5 e4 and be a
pawn up yeah I'm not sure if white
blacks should do that but that looks
reasonable it's also possible to play
Queen c2 here but then I think you could
take and play C 6 that's probably okay
okay so she played Knight f2 didn't go
crazy yet she does soon
yeah now she plays c5 and d6 yay White's
gonna win right see there you go she
just waited to go crazy she did it a
couple of moves later
what did black play actually doesn't
matter like every move wins but there's
two moves that win pretty easily
somebody suggests one of them Queen c7
Oh Queens he choose better than Queen c7
yeah Queen c2 probably wins also
probably yeah Queen c2 is probably okay
yeah he played Queen d4 96 was also very
good because Knight f4 check was a
threat yeah and then okay there's 30
pass pawns here so so black resigned
yeah so that game in itself wasn't great
it was pretty good but more important
was the next game he won because it
looked just like that game and that was
against a nice giri who just beat him
today but somehow I can't find that game
okay and they played our our opening we
just looked at although he played Knight
takes e5 so in this position
d4 was the most common move and that was
the game we saw Cara wanna be Michael
Adams rook e1 is being played now and if
you were here last year for the
Sinquefield Cup was anybody here same
field Cup three out of twenty
Sinquefield cup Carlsen anyone the
Sinquefield Cup this is the game that
Nakamura and Carlsen played and it's
also some anon games with Carlsen and so
forth okay and this is becoming popular
now also and basically this is all still
theory and basically black made a very
bad move in the middle game white got
the two bishops two bishops are good but
the positions really boring but White
has two bishops and black made a very
bad move in this position
very bad and probably this position is
about equal pawn structures are similar
okay I don't see why White's better
because White's bishops aren't so
powerful but here black being a movement
is almost losing after that and we would
call this an anti positional move that
gives you a good hint yeah
d4 is incredibly bad and when I showed
this to my fellow Grandmaster Brian
Smith what were the top being Brian
Smith were these guys terrible but being
Brian Smith okay and Brian's like d4
what kind of move is that and Gary's a
lot better than us but we don't like d4
now black has a black squared bishop
because I said so good reason and blacks
pawns are on white squares which means
his wife squared bishop is killing it
white has a white squared bishop blocked
by all of blacks pawns well this changes
everything now White's Bishop on f1 is
going to go to g2 and we're going to be
have a good Bishop and your Bishop on c7
was just blocked permanently by your
pawn on on d4 now normally this wouldn't
mean very much but white already has an
advantage of the two bishops so white
just trades everything off and then he
says hey your Bishop on b6 is bad
because you play d4 now if he was a
really good player he had move his pawn
back to d5 then he's all set that his
dish was great but that's why it's risky
to move pawns a lot because you can't
move him back and he traded off the
rooks and he said man my bishops are
better than your Bishop a knight your
Bishop at night can't move now the King
side is pretty blocked the center is
pretty blocked the Queen side is pretty
blocked and white has to open that up
for his bishops on the other hand this
bishops finished that's not going to do
anything this Knight wants to go to d5
then we got the e3 Square on d6 he can't
go anywhere he's not nothing can't do
anything but getting your d5 is going to
be tough and then when you actually
to get there eventually then it got
treated officer okay
so white played Queen a-one just like in
the previous game he played he learned
from himself okay he's going to bust
through on the Queen side and he did
Bishop c5 terrible and he busted through
on the Queen side and then when he
busted through on the Queen side just
like in the how you find game that he
busted through on the Kings side okay so
it looks like it's still a draw because
like how you going to win
well you can't bust through on the Queen
side anymore that's all blocked up the
Kings side looks like it's blocked up
but he busted through anyway by doing
nothing and then g4 so there's no puns
on the board but man those bishops are
starting to look good
I don't like blacks minor pieces I'm not
a fan
also black has three weak pawns those
pawns are like you know what would Lisa
Simpson say about this Bishop should say
a blockaded Bishop is of little value
you gotta learn how to play chess from
Lisa Simpson she's the smartest on The
Simpsons okay so this ship is pretty bad
the knight is pretty bad because if you
play like Knight d5 I'll play Queen aah
I can take it and my bishop is bishops
are going to be monsters okay and they
are good bishops and check and he traded
Queens and black has a white has a
passed pawn now and white has bishops
and actually this is the last blunder of
the game black has to play g5 here
probably still losing but close and
after Bishop h4 it's over because after
Bishop f6 check bad stuff's going to
happen like II 6 78 so he gave his final
a which is a funny move so that he could
play King g6 but yeah down upon two
bishops Knight takes a c2 and then he
took that he resigned after he gave his
Knight away yeah but that Bishop didn't
really have a great future on c5 once he
played the move d4 it's a terrible
positional move
one should have been here then white
would never have played at 4:00 then he
would have been fine and well this game
was moving MVL up to number eight in the
world soon to be number seven
until today Giri got his revenge now
I've been complaining about Giri for
years I hope you're watching this Anisha
Geary's like trying to take away the
Crown's of ponomaryov and lako as the
most boring player of all time he's
trying and if you look at Giri as
results that's all draws and when Giri
is playing a higher rated player he
really wants to draw even when he's
white now the reason I was saying all
this I'm dissing him is because this
tournaments the opposite he has a new
coach he has a new attitude and his
first four games were all decisive no
draws and that was funny he lost his
first two games so I make fun him for
different reasons but then he won his
next two games and then he lost this
game so after five rounds he had no
draws that's a different coach then he
drew in round six and he tweeted like
hey I drew I forgot what that was like
it was weird
okay then around seven he drew and then
around eight he drew and this is round
nine was today and he beat mvl but with
them again that you can find on the
internet um basically he played a
novelty in the opening that he had
prepared and he got an advantage the
whole game he lost some of his advantage
but mvl had was short on time mvl was
worse he couldn't defend a worse ending
he lost the knight and pawn ending upon
down so MV I'll still in clear first of
course and there's one round to go
tomorrow they're playing in Switzerland
usually in Europe and in fact possible
in the Sinquefield Cup but usually in
Europe the last round is much earlier
because they'd like to give prizes out
later the day and have a ceremony and
stuff like that and since it's much
later in Europe that means it's earlier
here so if they start at 2 p.m. that's
like 7 a.m. our time
if they start earlier let's give you
like 5 a.m. our time so the last round
is probably going to be between 4 & 6
a.m. our time probably when I was
watching the World Championship
in India we were getting up at 3:00 in
the morning and I watch the real
Championship button together and here up
you get up at 6:00 in the morning I
watch stuff ok so the last rounds
tomorrow and hopefully every all can
come back and win and make the Singh
feel Cup higher rated than than
otherwise
okay well look at one more game well
okay I like mvl so Caruana takes a back
seat this was a great game because
mostly have Russian player he prepared a
novelty and got a big advantage and got
a big time advantage and then when the
position was about equal then he fell
apart so they played the night off
Sicilian which is what MVL plays and
that's the sharpest most complicated and
his opponent knew he was going to ply it
so he was ready and he put this really
sharp line very complicated and I think
Nakamura has had white and black in
these positions because he likes sharp
uncompromising chess in this position
which is still theory still theory still
theory and this position mostly I've
played his new move that he was ready he
uses computers and he was all set and
previously I think why did played Knight
takes Knight but he played c3 never
before played and he probably analyzed
it for weeks that mvl seeing it for the
first time must now take a lot of time
to figure out what's going on well my
computer says black should play Knight
takes Knight and it's about equal nvl
played Knight f5 because that looks like
he's attacking the bishop on h4 and
after they traded white played Queen g5
for some reason all of whites laws were
played very quickly and recommended by
the computer because this was his
preparation he looked at night f5 and
this is what the computer told him to do
and mvl is thinking forever on every
move because he never saw c3 before so
it's looking bad for mvl he's walked
into his opponent's preparation
ok now White's threatening Queen takes
Knight so II 6 Queen takes g4
Bishop f6 because the bishop is pinned
at this point in the game black had 30
minutes left to get the time control and
White had only used 15 minutes because
he was still in his prep I think Natura
Bishop f6 he started thinking and mostly
I've thought for 40 minutes here because
you know how complicated and computer
actually said everything's better for
white including sacrificing the exchange
with Bishop takes f6 okay but he played
F takes G takes e6 sacrificing a piece
and that he castled and blacks King
looks a little iffy so White's a piece
down but White has everything White's
attacking the king the King is stock the
knight on h4 is pinned and well he
fought forever and computer says white
is better okay and MV I'll defended
perfectly
he played Queen takes f2 rook takes d6
rook takes d6 was not a good move the
computer wanted him to take on f7 and
play rook f1 and said white was better
but like 0.6 but okay here we need
supercomputers to help us because every
move is is crazy and rook takes d6 is
okay rook D it is the only move
according to the computer and he played
it and 92 was the best move which
shocked me I was watching the skin
during a chess camp and I was like well
Knight d4 seems like the logical move
but 92 was the computer movement then he
played it I guess Knight e4 and the
Knights pretty strong Queen e3 pinning
the knight takes black sting looks
really safe right dangerous
check the ship f6 Queen d7 now the this
is a first mistake of the game by Moshe
Leah first like real mistake white is
still better by playing a very strange
move Queen e4 and you would think why is
white trading Queens what he's down a
piece and attacking the reason is if you
take then your bishops attacked and
pinned how do you defend it
okay six and now I didn't see the
computer but I myself wondered what
happens on g4 threatening g5 and I still
wonder that so I'm guessing that's why
computer lights Queen e4 and after Queen
e4 computer said White has a nice
advantage I think it was letting white
play queen's eggs b7 check okay but
trading queens are sort of
counterintuitive for white white played
aggressive move Queen to d3 King g7 and
whites still attacking but blacks
defending really well and here now white
doesn't have enough for a piece anymore
so now blacks finally winning and Queen
h5 and now every move was a mistake
until the final move which even
Grandmaster Ken west will laugh at you
getting ready to laugh now that's saying
a lot
white played Queen h5 which is a mistake
black said yummy yummy yummy and now why
plated with its incomprehensible even
cran west would never consider such a
move and whites 2700 but he's in time
trouble so time trouble we make mistakes
so he's down a piece for a pawn here
this is going to lose anyway but he
played incredibly bad move Knight to c5
not a good move
not recommended by Joe Gagne a 2700 feet
a can West what did black do this is
your chance highly recommended you can
do it especially if you listen to other
people yeah
Queen a1 and takes the rook on f1 yeah
normally these players don't let you do
that but these in time trouble and
things weren't working out this game he
sacked 2-piece and his attack sort of
dissipated and then okay he resigned
because he hung his rook on f1 so those
are the games won by Maxine vascular
gras from France
Fabiana Caruana who plays for Italy but
that's about all he has to do with Italy
his name's Italian that's pretty good
and those players will be here in almost
exactly one month for the Sinquefield
Cup and I expect they'll both do quite
well fact if you just look at these
games they win every game they play
we'll look at the other games again the
six player will either be Sergey
Karjakin which is likely and if he's not
able to play
it'll be st. Louis's own nobody knows
who lives in st. Louis Wesley so that's
right so either car yakin or so if car
yakin plays it seems very likely it'll
be the highest-rated tournament in
history estimated rating 2803 feet a
plus tax yeah that's what history is
yeah if it's Wesley so it might be
second or first it depends on the
ratings in July and August and such so
well let's see the sing feel Cup and now
you can root for your two favorite
players MVL and Fabiano cara wanna class
dismissed
you